that's right folks I woke up in the
morning afternoon I found out there's a
Deadpool - trailer not just a trailer
it's alright it's total Deadpool spoof
it's a Bob Ross video right when it
started I perked up I was like you gotta
be kidding me
I love Bob Ross do his videos are on
Netflix you said watch I do when I was a
kid it's like a Bugs Bunny cartoon he's
like alright folks there's a painting
it's Deadpool being Bob Ross and at
first it went over my head for the first
couple names but the names of the
paint's are name's Betty white men in
black Clockwork Orange
it starts out like a Bob Ross painting
and then cuts away and there's like a
whole painting there I mean yeah there's
a quick montage of Deadpool - footage
new like drew Barrymore in firestarter
it's totally gonna be a fire starter
right from somewheres got right but this
trailer perfectly illustrates why I
don't want Disney to own all the rights
remember I believe it was last week fans
were getting really excited there might
be a trade between the Marvel properties
that Fox owns and Marvel Studios and it
looks like that was a rumor now that's
not happening the sake of this video is
talking about that for a second Marvel
Studios then owned those characters of
Marvel Studios own Deadpool that would
mean Disney owns Deadpool if Disney
owned the x-men rights the Logan movie
we got would not have been the Logan
movie we got do you really want Logan
changes at all I don't and if it
happened now Deadpool - most certainly
would not be ready to our Deadpool 3
definitely not I'm thinking about
thinking that Fantastic Four though I
think they'd be cool but if Disney did
own Deadpool do you think this trailer
would have had anything like holy [ __ ]
knuckles I am high as a kite right now
god I love cocaine
alright I'm gonna call from Ken no which
is why I think Deadpool is safest not
with the MCU that's right that feels
good it's what Bob wants to do he take
his paintbrush you'd be like trailer
ends with a painting that I am NOT gonna
lie I would pay for that painting my
life is missing that official painting
and he finishes off the trailer with the
mantra of life so from our family to
yours keep your pants dry your dreams
wet and remember hugs death drugs and
for the most part we agree with you I
see jokes like this I don't feel like
it's made by some crusty old guys in
some corporate building a lot of that
kids laughing at tonight Johnson I don't
know sir but I'm pretty sure if we
mentioned minecraft that'll track Wow
perfect let's craft some minds so
anything is they went way older than
that but also loves by everybody because
Bob Ross all in all it looks like the
marketing campaign for Deadpool 2 is in
line with Deadpool 1 very meta humor
that is also very connected with the
people who watch it right guys for the
Deadpool 2 trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]